le méga fichiers soulève de plus en plus
de critiques le conseil national du
numérique organe consultatif a demandé
ce matin sa suspension immédiate
comment ce fichier peut être aussi très
intrusif si on change de gouvernement et
moi je n'ai pas une confiance instinctif
comme ça et naturelle dans ce que
pourrait faire un brice hortefeux ou
l'extrême droite avec un tel fichier
demain cette fois c'est officiel c'est
yannick jadot qui a gagné le droit de
représenter europe écologie à les verts
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
et la remporter le deuxième tour de la
primaire devant sa rivale michèle rivasi
sprint final aux états unis donald trump
a traversé cinq états pour faire cinq
meetings tout ça en une seule journée
le fbi a il ne va finalement pas
poursuivre hillary clinton dans la
sphère des emails qui empoisonnent sa
campagne depuis des mois voir elle est
protégée par un système corrompu
affirme-t-il c'est un système totalement
corrompu ça fait longtemps que je le dis
vous ne pouvez pas analysé six cent
cinquante mille nouveaux e-mails envie
jour par barack obama vient même en
renfort et aux la moquerie au sujet du
candidat républicain
privé de son compte twitter par ses
conseillers pour éviter les dérapages
si quelqu'un n'est pas capable de
maîtriser son compte twitter alors qu'en
sera-t-il pour les codes nucléaires
l'élection de trump serait un drame un
gramme pour le monde parce que cet homme
est proprement irresponsable et
dangereux vous vous seriez donc il
arrive ce qui représente tout ce que
vous combattez dieu merci je ne suis pas
américain
alors ce sera l'apocalypse annoncée
selon vous tram ce serait un immense
risque ce serait des zones mais de toute
façon c'est déjà navrant pour les états
unis qu un histrion comme ça atteignent
45 % ça interpelle beaucoup pour ce qui
était supposé être la plus belle
démocratie du monde
or il se trouve que si madame clinton
l'emportent ce n'est pas si rose que ce
qu'on nous dit mais mme clinton c'est la
candidate qui veut faire passer le
traité transatlantique le taffetas et on
a fait passer malheureusement le trait
avec le canada là ce serait le traité du
boeuf aux hormones des ogm le taffetas
elle l est pour trump est contre car ce
n'est pas la fidélité qui l'étouffent
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui parle de vous
ben je vais
il répondu dans un petit texto très
simplement je ne suis pas un homme
politique qui te dois un mandat je ne
suis pas un fait à la vie d'un souverain
nous avons un désaccord politique
majeure et je pense que je peux apporter
plus dans la vie qu'une m'a donné où la
charia la lecture du livre daniel
j'étais tellement consterné que j'ai
consacré une partie de mon intervention
à cela en disant devant le premier
ministre qu'à mon sens l'article 68 la
question de l'article 68 se posait une
roue de bris demande quand même fait
c'est une cinquantaine d'euros voilà
comme ça vous le savez je suis arrivé à
la conclusion que au delà des questions
d'opportunité politique puis siège dans
mon camp des gens qui pensent que
hollande est tellement faible qu'il faut
surtout pas lui faire quoi que ce soit
il est très bien comme ça il est
tellement faible que c'est le meilleur
candidat possible
moi je pense qu'il ya des questions de
fond qui sont posées j'ai l'honneur de
déclarer ouverte la coop 22
oui